away from the capital across the country
there are places of quiet reflection
in the ruins of coventry's gothic
cathedral the altar has become the focus
somewhere for people to pause reflect
and pay their respects
she just felt like the nation's
grandmother she'll just be sorely missed
you know would have liked to have gone
down to london but
i just felt it would be nice to sort of
you know stay in my home city and
you know just bring down some flowers
for her
wherever they are people are finding
their own ways to say goodbye however
small
or big
this mural was commissioned by the
owners of the house behind this wall in
nuneaton
the people who live here wanted a
permanent public tribute to the queen
she's just been an absolutely beautiful
queen for for all of my life and
you know my mum my nan all look up to
the queen and she's just she's just been
our constant and for us it's about
celebrating a historic moment not just
the sad passing but also
the life that she gave to all of us the
queen of trees is this one it's the
beach tree schools have been helping
children to cope with loss
here in birmingham they've decided to
dedicate this garden to the queen
the pupils encouraged to talk about what
she meant to them there's been a genuine
sense of sadness for many of their
children
because we had celebrated the jubilee
just just in june
the queen has felt more significant to
them and more real to them and i think
that's that has impacted on them
for so many this loss has felt personal
people moved to do something
across the country there are plans for
the funeral to be shown on big screens
so that communities can come together to
mourn
a national moment marked by so many in
their own quiet way
becky johnson sky news coventry